hello and uh thank you for this
opportunity to present our talk to what
i understand is a wide audience so this
is very exciting
today i'm going to be talking about a
symptom recovery which is an inducible
form of plant tolerance to virus
infection in plants
and i'm going to talk about the
molecular mechanisms that are regulating
symptom recovery
but before i do that i first wanted to
give you a brief introduction of the
infection cycle of positive strand rna
plant viruses and i'm going to take
tomato ring spot virus as an example
because this is our favorite virus and
that's the virus i'll be describing and
using as a model system in the rest of
the talk
so viruses will first infect the cells
and there enter the cells as a
uncapsidated viral
particle
after decapsidation the viral rna will
be released and the first things that
needs to happen is the viral rna must be
translated
and this will happen through
using the translation machinery of the
host
so the virus completely dependent on its
host for this step and for actually all
the step of its infection cycle
after translation
you have release of the viral protein
and in the case of many plant viruses
about half of plant viruses including
tomato ring spot virus
a polyprotein is released that is then
cleaved by a viral protease
once the mature viral proteins are there
you have formation of viral rna
replication complex
and basically the rna and the
replication protein encoded by the virus
will assemble
with uh in complexes that are in
association with intracellular membrane
from the host
and what will happen is that you will
have this massive membrane proliferation
and you can see this on this em picture
that i showed on the corner of the slide
and that i represented here
on the
right of the side as membrane vesicles
this complex will allow the formation of
a new
viral rna progeny
which is then encapsulated and that
requires the viral code protein
and eventually the virus will move from
cell to cell into the next cells and in
the case of tomato ring sponsors it does
that through the formation of tubular
structure
so a few points i want to make about
this uh
replication cycle is that first viruses
hijack and modify host intracellular
membranes and proteins facilitate their
infection so they're completely
dependent on their host
and also virus infection can cause
profound change in the plant physiology
and that can be one of the causes of
visible symptoms and the disease
also
what
perhaps the most important point is that
viruses depend on the fit hose to
multiply
so if the hose is too damaged that will
also hinder the virus infection cycle
now plants defend themselves against
virus infection one of the first thing
they do in recognition of a pathogen
attack is induce defense response and
this happens by a
reprogramming of the transcriptome in
the nucleus and activation of defense
genes
then uh one of the pathways that are
activated targets degradation of the
viral rna and this can happen with rna
silencing mechanism or with rna dk
pathways
another strategy used by plants is
translation repression so blocking the
translation of the viral irony and this
can happen in a specific manner by rna
silencing and i'm going to show you an
example of this
the plants can also defend itself by
specifically degrading viral proteins
through one of the plant degradation
pathway
and also
here there is activation of salicylic
acid mediated response that can do many
things but mostly block the viral
movement through the plants
and so all of these defense response
they're not always all activated but
there is always multiple layers of plant
defense that are activated in cells that
are infected by plant viruses
the virus
counter-attacked
the plants and so there are counter
defense responses
uh viruses have way to
uh reprogram themselves the plant
transcriptome to prevent the induction
of defense responses
they also encodes profane to suppress
rna silencing and prevent the
degradation of rlrna or the repression
of the translation
viruses actually have learned to use the
plant degradation pathways to eliminate
plant defense proteins so they use the
own plant defense response against the
plant
and viruses also encode proteins to
counteract salicylic acid mediated
responses and again many of those things
can happen simultaneously in the plant
so there are multiple layers of plant
virus interactions
and i'm going to describe a little bit
more rna silencing because it's one of
the main defense response of the plant
um and it's initiated by the production
of double strand rnas which are normally
not found in plants so it's recognized
as a foreign object
and it's they are produced during the
steps of viral replication
they are recognized by dicer-like
enzymes from the plants which will then
cleave this rna to produce small
interfering rnas those small interfering
rnas which are specific for the virus
are incorporated into rna silencing
induced complex also called risk and
those complex contain one argonaut
protein which we abbreviate as ago
and then there will be sequence specific
silencing and most of the time this will
result in the cleavage of the viral rna
at the site corresponding to the binding
of the
small interfering rna so there is a
sequence specific silencing in this case
this is a very simplified version of rna
science thing there are more steps but
i'm just presenting you a simplified
version one thing that i do want to say
though is that there are multiple
silencing pathways occurring in the
plants and there are multiple ago
proteins and plants for example in their
arabidopsis tanyana which is a model
host there are 10 different argonaut
proteins that play roles on different
pathways
and viral suppressors of sciencing can
block one or several steps of these
pathway
so i think i've tried to highlight that
there is a complex layers of plant virus
interaction and and these interaction
will
uh determine the outcome of infection
and so you can see this as a gradient of
plant virus interaction
where if you consider the plant fitness
in green at the top and the virus
fitness in red at the bottom
you can see that in the case of a
resistant interaction
the plant fitness will be very high but
the virus will not replicate to very
high level in a susceptible interaction
the plant will get diseased and you will
have a low fitness of the plant and the
virus will replicate at high level
but there is this in between stage which
we refer to as tolerance and which you
could consider as the perfect balancing
act
and in this case the virus is still
present but caused little damage to the
plant
this is advantages for the plants
because the plant defenses are primed
and so it's uh responding better to the
presence of the virus but it's also an
advantage for the virus because the
virus persists it keeps its host fit and
it is transmissible to other plants
so now i'm going to introduce symptom
recovery so it's a phenomenon that was
actually
already described in 1928 by vingardt
and i'm showing you here the original
picture uh from the wingard paper where
what he showed is that when you have a
plant that is initially
diseased
by as a result of infection with nipple
virus
you will then find that later in
infection new leaves emerge that are
asymptomatic and they look completely
healthy but in fact they still have
virus in there
so
this was an interesting phenomenon and
nobody really knew what uh
was
the molecular mechanism regulating this
it's only at the end of the 90s that it
was recognized that symptom recovery
from a nipple virus
is linked with the induction of plant
antiviral rna silencing
and what they showed is that the viral
rna concentration is reduced in the
recovered leaves and this happened in
the sequence specific manner but the
virus persists and it is transmissible
to other plants
and so
this raised the interesting question of
whether symptom recovery is a form of
inducible tolerance so the plant gets to
that disease state first but then gets
into that happy medium where it's
still healthy
but maintains the virus
so i'm going to give you a little bit
more introduction about tomato ring spot
virus
so those are the virus particles so it's
a spherical virus and those are the
symptoms that are produced on an initial
leave it's a serious pathogens of fruit
trees and small fruits in north america
so it's transmitted by seeds and
nematodes
it has a very wide host range including
many herbaceous hosts who often in the
field will serve as reservoir for the
virus but because it has such a wide
host range it's a very good model system
to study plant virus interaction
and it belongs to the genus nipple virus
family security which contains many
other important pathogens
and tomato ring spot virus consists of
two rnas each of the rnas
encode one large polyprotein which is
cleaved by the viral protease the viral
protease is encoded by rna1 rna1 also
encodes other proteins involved in the
replication of the virus and rna-2
involves the code protein which
encapsulates the particle and the
movement protein which assets in the
cell cell movement of the virus
now let me get to the the meat of the
talk and uh i want to show you what
happens when the nicosiana bantamiana
plat is inoculated with tomato ring spot
virus
and you will see symptoms on the
inoculated leaf
and and you will see here a close-up of
a lesion on the inoculated leave and you
can understand why it's called tomato
ring spot virus
and so this is what happens on the
inoculated leaf and then later in
infection the virus will move up to
upper leaves and you will end up with
systemic symptoms that often correspond
to vein clearing so it's a kind of a
necrosis along the veins
but
much later in infection then you will
see that the plants completely recover
from infection and the new leaves are
apparently healthy
so the first thing that we did when we
started
looking at this phenomenon is to see how
much virus is actually present in those
leaves at the different stage of
infection
and we expected that there would be less
virus in the recovered leaf because this
is what had been reported for other
nipple viruses
but to our surprise the level of viral
rna were maintained during the course of
infection and in fact there were very
high level of viral irony in the
recovered leaf as i'm showing you here
on this northern plot
so then the next question was okay
there's still a lot of viral ionia is
rna silencing active against tomato ring
spot virus in recovered leaf
so what we did to that is we compared
two types of plants plants that were
healthy or leaves that were recovered
from tomorrow's v infection
and we
injected those leaves
with
two types of constructs
one was
so in each case we had the green
fluorescent protein as a reported gene
and in the bottom comes to up here
where i show this little square in the
red those are tomato ring spot virus
sequence
so the idea is that if silencing is
already pre-induced against tomato ring
spot virus it should target this
construct and prevent its expression and
in fact this is what we saw if you look
on the bottom panels
on the right here you can see that in
healthy plants the green fluorescence
protein is expressed very well and we
see high level of fluorescence but it's
not expressed in tomato rigs but as far
as recovered leaves indicating that
financing against tomorrow's v is active
in doing sleeves
and we have a control where the the bit
of sensor
gene that we added is from a different
virus cucumber necrosis virus and in
this case the gfp protein is expressed
very well into
healthy and recovered leaf so this
indicated to us that rna silencing
specific to tamari tomato ring spot
virus was active in recovered leaves
another thing that we did is to look
whether small rnas were present and
especially those that were specific for
tomato ring spot virus so we use
northern blots again and we could show
that indeed there is small rna specific
for tomato ring spot virus active in
these leaves
so this tells us that
yes irony silencing is active but it's
not managing to bring down the
concentration of our lining
so something else is happening
um and i forgot to mention that all the
work i've uh presented before was the
beautiful work of uh
i'm going to go back to that side of
juan rafael and melanie walker and i'm
indicating the reference to the journal
at the end
at the bottom of the slide
at that point uh new student came in the
lab bachelor dev goshau
and he was interested in looking at the
molecular mechanism of this in more
detail and we took advantage of an
interesting phenomenon that
the
symptom recovery is actually dependent
on the growth temperature of the plants
and so you can see that plants grown at
27 degrees
will go through a phase of infection and
disease in inoculated leave and in
symptomatic leave but will eventually
recover from infection and if you look
at the picture of the plants on the
right sides at 20 dpi it's a reasonably
happy plant
the same virus infected on the same
batch of plant but let grown at 21
degrees you will see that the plants
really get very severely diseased and is
unable to recover from infection
so um what bashu dev did is to look at
what's happening in those leaves treated
at 21 degrees or 27 degrees and we
looked at
initial
leaves or leaves later in infection that
in 21 degrees were severely diseased or
in 27 degrees were recovered
and he first looked at the concentration
of viral rlrna and showed the same as
we had shown before
where the
concentration of rlrna was maintained in
recovery
but interestingly when he looked at the
level of viral protein he saw that while
there was a high concentration of viral
proteins early in infection at 27
degrees there was very little viral
protein later in infection
in contrast at 21 degrees at the same
time at eight days post infection you
have very high concentration of viral
protein so something is happening there
and to try to figure out what's
happening
is uh
that should have used uh methods of in
vivo labeling where he detached leaves
at different stage of infection
and then
incubated dose with labeled methionine
which would label all the proteins that
are actively being translated and then
heated and immunoprecipitation with code
protein specific antibody to purify the
code protein and to look by
polyacrylamide gel electrophoresis
to look at the labeling of these
proteins
and what i'm going to show you first is
just a comment blue stain gel so we're
looking here at all the proteins present
in the
in these leaves and you can see that
early in infection
uh you have
an increasing amount of protein but then
later on the level of
a code protein diminished and the code
protein is shown by the red arrows here
and then when we looked at what was
actually labeled that's when we got a
very interesting result because we
noticed that proteins were actively
labeled early in infection but were not
labeled later in infection
so this indicated to us that the
translation of the viral rnas were
actually repressed during infection
the next thing that uh by abbas should
have did is uh to look at the role of
different argonaut proteins in this
phenomenon and i mentioned to you that
arabidox italian encode many different
argonauts protein but we looked at
argonaut 1 and argonaut 2 predominantly
because these two proteins were
previously reported to be involved in
plant virus resistance and we also
looked at argonaut 4 as a control and
what you can see here what we did is to
specifically uh knock down the
expression of either ago 1 i go two or i
go four
and you can see that plants that were
knocked down for i go one were unable to
recover from infections while hell uh
controlled plants or plants uh knocked
down for i go two or i go 4 could
recover from infection
and when the
when bashu
looked at
the concentration of viral rna and cold
protein he could see a high
concentration of rlrna in all of these
plants uh all of the recovered plant the
tomorrow's the infected plants but only
in the argonaut one deficient plant
could he see the cold protein being
produced
so uh from this we have a model for the
an ago one dependent translation
repression associated with symptom
recovery to tomato ring spot virus
infection
in which so the first step is what i
showed you before but now we can say
that when plants are grown at 27 degrees
and infected with tumeric storing spot
virus the sir a are probably
incorporated by ago one and rather than
causing the cleavage of rlini this
caused a blockage of the translation of
the viral irony
so this was one of the first example
where
translation repression what's shown as a
mechanism
to
uh
silence of viral ironies
so i told you before that viruses defend
themselves
against plant defense response
and
we looked at several protein but i'm
going to show you our results with the
tomato rig spot virus code protein
and we have evidence that it suppress
financing of gfp reported gene
and so i'm first going to introduce the
system we take healthy plants and we
express
high level of the green fluorescence
reporter gene and because we're
expressing high level of this this will
induce the plant rna silencing
against this gfp reported gene
and then we can co-express viral protein
and see if they suppress the gfp
silencing so here i'm first going to
show you the control experiments where
when the gfp is expressed alone we have
production of small amounts of gfp
protein
nfgfp messenger rna but we see
high levels of small interfering rna
corresponding to the gfp and that
indicates to us that the silencing is
indeed active against the green
fluorescence protein when we add the
thomas virus p19 protein which is very
well known suppressor of simencing
we have an increase in the amount of gfp
protein and increase in the level of gfp
messenger rna and a decrease in the
level of gfps irony and this is because
this protein sequesters the sirnis to
prevent the silencing
now when we look at the tomarsvi code
protein what would happen we added the
tomato protein we see an induction of
the gfp protein produced
but no effect on the concentration of
gfp messenger rna and no effect on the
gfp
rnas so it's a completely different
mechanism of silencing suppression
and
we suspected that it might have to do
with the level of translation of gfp
mrna
so we use a different uh in vivo uh a
met a same method of in vivo labeling
that i described before and we could see
that indeed the translation rate of gfp
was greatly increased in plants that
were
co-inoculated with some rsv code
proteins
and this was the work of regita kiran in
the lab
now
i have to say that
although we did see um
silencing suppression with the code
protein it was not always as efficient
as i'm showing you here it depended on
the specific conditions and so we would
rather refer to the thomasville code
protein as a rather weak suppressor of
silencing
and so now we have an updated model
where i'm still showing you what i
showed you before with
the presence of argonaute 1 which
repressed the translation of rlrna but
now we have the tamarsde code protein
that will prevent this mechanism
and
we allow the production of viral rna
translation but as i said this is not a
very efficient mechanism so there is a
balance between the silencing
suppression and the silencing
and one of the ways that the tamaris
vehicle protein does that is that it
used the plants degradation machinery to
regulate the degradation of argonaut one
but to and i'm not going to have time to
show you all this data but we also have
evidence that the plants counteract by
in turn regular doing a regulated
degradation of the cold protein so it's
a very highly regulated mechanism
now
at this point we were also interested in
seeing what would happen with other
isolates and uh with other temperatures
so i'm introducing you not to isolate
ras one is the isolate that i described
to you before which we cover at 27
degrees but it's very necrotic at 21
degrees
and gyv is a mild strain with plants
recovering at both temperature
and what was interesting is that
silencing of argonaut 1 did not prevent
symptom recovery from the mild strain at
21 degrees and so we thought there is
probably a different mechanism happening
and possibly another argonaut one
involved
so
came in the lab at that point and this
is work that was also initiated by uh
bashadev ghoshal and sushma josie also
participated in this work
and
basically what uh dinesh did was to look
at the induction of another argonaut
that is a well-known antiviral
enzyme and we found that if we look at
the level of messenger rna during the
course of infection
we're seeing a spite of induction of
argonaut 2 messenger rna in both rasp 1
and gyv infected plants early in
infection
and but then when he looked at the our
level of argan of two protein we got a
little bit of a surprise
all the plants that later recovered from
infection and i'm showing you this with
the green circle
showed a high level of argonaut 2
protein early in infection
but under conditions where plant did not
recover from infection as shown in red
here we did not see an accumulation of
argonaut 2 protein
so this was interesting to us
and we did a bunch of experiments which
i'm not going to have time to show you
to you today and we showed that in fact
argonaut 2 degradation is differentially
regulated in tomorrow's the infected
plants
so then we thought okay argonaut 2 is
induced it's only the protein is only
present in plants that are later going
to recover infection does it play a role
in symptom recovery
so we collaborated with a group in
hungary the whole group of carolee fatio
which had produced argonaut two
deficient plants
and what to our surprise what we found
is that even though uh argonaut two
deficient plants showed increased
accumulation of rlrna and viral
proteins in fact they still recovered
from infection
so next uh what dinesh did was to
look again at
the
expression of different argonauts so i'm
showing you argonaut 2 here i showed you
this data before so in wild type protein
uh plants the argonaut two protein is uh
induced
early in infection in argonaut two
deficient plant it's not there is still
a little bit of argon up too but at much
higher lower level
and
argonaut 1
is actually expressed pretty
constitutively regardless of the state
of infection
but what we saw is that argonaut 5 and
argonaut 7 are also upregulated during
tomato ring spot virus infection
so at this point we're thinking that
it's likely that there's various
argonauts that could play complementary
and overlapping roles uh during
recovery to tomato rings by virus
infection
and so the take-home message now are
that different molecular mechanism
regulates symptom recovery and the
balance between plant defense and virus
contour defense determine the outcome of
infection and this is influenced by our
environmental conditions
uh we're still doing some work on this
we're looking at transcriptomic analysis
of symptomatic and recovery to see what
else is happening there
but the main take-home message that i
want to leave you with is that the best
adapted virus is one that does not
damage its host too much but that still
managed to persist and i also want to
state that this is quite often observed
in natural environments actually
and i'm just going to finish by thanking
the lab members and collaborators i've
talked about the work of juan rovell
melanie walker bashadev goshal vegeta
karan zinesh babufodel and sushma jusi
during my talk we have collaborators
carolee fatiol that produce provided us
with the igo2 mutant peter muffet and
herman schultz are paying for specters
for sciencing of argonauts and uh i'm
also acknowledging funding from
agriculture in niger food canada and
from an insert discovery grant
and
i take any question from here